up until now we have analyzed the motion
of objects that we treated as so-called
point masses we're literally all of the
mass of the object was treated as lying
at a single point this is obviously an
unrealistic idealization real objects
have spatial extent and come in various
sizes and shapes some regular and some
highly irregular the mass distribution
within these extended objects might be
smooth and uniform or highly non-uniform
and lumpy moreover sometimes we will be
interested in simultaneously analyzing a
large system of particles or objects to
deal properly with such situations it is
necessary to introduce a new physical
quantity called the momentum which is a
vector that we traditionally denote with
the symbol P for a single point mass the
momentum is a product of the mass and
the velocity vector the form of Newton's
second law that we have used so far F
equals MA is actually only true for the
special case of a point mass the more
general form of Newton's second law is
that F equals DP DT that is that the
force is equal to the time derivative of
the momentum vector this is applicable
to either a single particle or to a
system of particles this more general
form provides us a way to address
extended objects or multi particle
systems we will once again appeal to a
calculus like argument breaking down an
extended distribution into a large
number of small elements treating each
element separately and then summing the
results as part of this process we will
introduce the concept of the center of
mass a sort of mass weighted average
position for an extended object or
system momentum is also the first of
several special measurable quantities
that we will discuss that obey special
powerful rules called conservation laws
the other two quantities are energy and
angular momentum conservation laws are
principles that provide that the given
measurable quantity remains unchanged
during the evolution of a system with
time as long as certain requirements are
met essentially the requirement that a
system remains isolated with this
restriction in place the possible
evolution of motion of a particle
or system of particles is greatly
restricted simplifying this calculation
we will see how this can be used to our
advantage in understanding what will
happen